bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler d'aristote
aristote est un philosophe grec de
l'antiquité
ivème siècle avant jésus-christ il a été
le disciple de platon ce qui n'empêchera
pas d'être en désaccord avec lui sur de
nombreuses questions
et comme la plupart des philosophes à
cette époque aristote s'intéressait à
tout il s'intéressait à tout c'est à
dire aussi bien à la métaphysique qu'à
la morale à la science ou à la politique
et donc aujourd'hui c'est à la politique
qu'on va s'intéresser
ou plus exactement à la question de
savoir en quoi l'homme serait selon la
célèbre formule d'aristote un animal
politique
c'est une expression qui est entré dans
les usages mais c'est une expression qui
est aussi souvent mal comprise
et c'est pourquoi je vous propose
aujourd'hui de nous pencher sur cette
formule pour tenter de comprendre la
pensée qu'il ya derrière
la pensée qui conduit à définir l'homme
comme un animal politique
et vous allez voir qu'on va trouver
derrière cette formule une réflexion
très riche une réflexion très profonde
sur la nature de l'homme et sur ce
qu'implique le fait de vivre en société
jammes commençons par évacuer une
première confusion une première
confusion possible en tout cas qui
serait de croire que l'expression animal
politique signifierait que nous serions
tous intéressés par la politique ou que
nous devrions tous exercé des fonctions
politiques
pas du tout ça
ça même si cette interprétation n'est
pas aberrante en soi
si on tient compte du fait qu'à athènes
les citoyens exercer effectivement des
fonctions politiques
être citoyen d'athènes c'était déjà un
statut politique
mais c'était pas du tout ça qu'il faut
entendre à travers la phrase l'homme est
un animal politique
en fait il faudrait plutôt entendre le
mot politique comme un synonyme de
social
l'homme est un animal politique ça veut
dire l'homme est un animal social
qui permet de dire ça et bien c'est le
fait que timo logiquement la police qui
a donné le mot politique c'est la cité
produits
société
un animal politique ça veut donc tout
simplement dire vivre en société
sam on n'a pas dit grand chose
parce que dire que les êtres humains
vivent en société
c'est pas un scoop
oui les hommes ne vivent pas seule dans
la forêt on sait
mais ce qu'on sait moins en tout cas ce
qui serait intéressant de savoir
c'est pourquoi
qu'est ce qui fait que les hommes vivent
rassembler plutôt qu'isolé
évident
et c'est d'autant moins évident si on
pense comme le pensent et freud que
l'être humain n'est peut-être pas fait
pour vivre en société
qui n'est peut-être pas fait pour aimer
ses semblables
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
l'homme n'est pas fait pour vivre en
société ça veut dire que l'être humain
n'est pas animé par l'innocence et la
bienveillance
mais qui est au contraire animé par la
pulsion et la destruction
pour freud faire cohabiter les hommes
c'est faire cohabiter des forces
adversaires
des pulsions adversaires
d'où le fameux malaise dans la
civilisation dont par le freud qui
désigne le fait que les membres d'une
société sont obligés de réprimer leurs
pulsions pour vivre ensemble
et que cette répression pulsionnel crée
de la frustration et de la névrose
pour freud nous sommes tous des névrosés
parce que nous sommes tous contraints de
retenir nos pulsions face à l'autre
si les hommes ne sont pas faits pour
vivre en société
pourquoi le font-ils
et bien la première raison que donne
aristote du fait que nous vivions en
société
c'est le besoin
le besoin de quoi le besoin des autres
parce que sans les autres
survivre
vivre seule dans la forêt pour reprendre
cette image
c'est compliqué
parce que la forêt est peuplé d'animaux
style
des animaux que je ne peut pas vaincre
si je suis seul
et même sans parler des animaux
climat
il faut bien se protéger du froid les
intempéries
donc construire des abris les abris
étanche
les abris composé de matériaux lourds
faut bien les porter ces matériaux pour
construire un abri
et l'individu seul
pas la force suffisante pour les porter
je prends des exemples volontairement
basique parce que je voudrais vous
sentiez à quel point c'est concret le
problème du besoin
le problème de l'interdépendance des
individus
c'est le problème de la limite
l'individu seul est limité
sion et s'associer étymologiquement ça
veut dire s'unir
ça veut dire le faire quand
cyan les uns aux autres les individus
deviennent beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus capable
dix hommes ensemble peuvent soulever une
voiture
seul ne le peut pas
si l'essai dix fois
donc l'adage selon lequel l'union fait
la force il vient d'abord de là
du caractère multiplicateur de
l'association
et quand l'association est dirigée vers
l'action elle devient
coopération
ono
jr
on travaille à plusieurs et ce faisant
on crée des choses qui serait
inenvisageable de créer pour un individu
seul
voilà pourquoi la solidarité s'appelle
la solidarité
parce que la solidarité créée la
solidité
donc rires c'est le meilleur moyen
d'optimiser ses chances de survie
sans compter ses conditions de vie
dans un vocabulaire moderne on pourrait
dire que l'association c'est un avantage
évolutif
coopérer est un avantage évolutif
je vous recommande à ce sujet les
ouvrages de kropotkine
théoricien anarchiste qui s'intitule
l'entr'aide un facteur de l'évolution
et donc vivre en société c'est
bénéficier des compétences des autres
pour soi en échange de ces compétences à
soi pour les autres
c'est le principe même de l'organisation
sociale
la complémentarité des aptitudes au
service de la stabilité collective
on pourra aller jusqu'à dire du bonheur
collectif
si tenté que heures
cuire à une question matérielle
pour revenir
son d'aristote
ça la signification de l'homme est un
animal politique
l'homme est un animal contraint de
s'associer avec ses semblables pour
survivre
alors maintenant expliquer en quoi
l'homme était un être politique entendue
au sens d'être social
il faut maintenant s'arrêter sur le
choix du mot animal
aristote était un naturaliste
il étudiait la biologie animale avec
plus ou moins de réussite
et donc ce n'est pas un hasard s'il
utilise son vocabulaire
fait dire que l'homme est un animal
politique c'est dire deux choses
c'est dire premièrement que l'homme est
un animal
dir deuxièmement
qu'il est un animal à part
mal pas tout à fait comme les autres
allez de l'homme comme d'un animal
politique c'est une manière de dire que
sa dimension politique que sa dimension
sociale donc le distingue des autres
animaux
quel le caractérise en propre
savez c'est quelque chose qu'on trouve
souvent chez les philosophes l'idée du
trait distinctif de l'être humain
et du propre de l'homme
aristote le propre de l'homme c'est la
vie en société
c'est l'association les individus et la
complémentarité des compétences
elham on pourrait rétorquer aristote que
la coopération n'est pas le propre de
l'homme
aussi coopèrent
les fourmis coopèrent
et même si on prend simplement le
critère de la coexistence du fait de
vivre en groupe alors là énormément
d'animaux sont concernés
énormément d'animaux ont une existence
grégaire
grégaire qu'on retrouve dans agrégé
houdan et gregor ça veut dire qu'ils
forment un groupe
qui s'agglomèrent
donc de ce point de vue là peut-on
vraiment parler d'une spécificité
humaine quant au fait de vivre en groupe
bien pour aristote oui
il ya une spécificité humaine et cette
spécificité consiste dans l'instrument
que les hommes utilisent pour coopérer
et cet instrument c'est le langage
bien sûr aristote n'avait pas nos
connaissances actuelles en éthologie
n'avait pas connaissance du fait qu'il
existe un langage chez les animaux mais
en réalité ce n'est pas très grave parce
que ce que dit aristote du langage
humain par rapport au langage animal
reste valable
à savoir que le langage humain permet
d'exprimer des choses qu'on ne retrouve
pas dans le langage animal
est ce que permet le langage humain par
rapport au langage animal c'est
l'expression du jugement
c'est ça la caractéristique du langage
humain
l'expression du jugement
or le jugement c'est ce qui permet
d'établir des règles
hier des lois
et normes de comportement
c'est à dire des choses indispensables à
la coexistence humaine
pour qu'il y ait coexistence pour qu'il
y ait communauté
il y est monde commun
un monde commun à dire un monde dans
lequel on partage un certain nombre de
pratiques et de conception qui justifie
ces pratiques
et donc si l'homme est le seul animal à
pouvoir exprimer des jugements
ça veut dire que l'homme était le seul
animal à pouvoir être qualifié d' animal
politique
parce que c'est le seul animal capable
d'instaurer des normes de vie collective
en fonction du jugement de ce qui est
juste et de ce qui ne l'est pas
langage humain est le seul à rendre
possible l'expression de la notion de
justice
donc c'est marc caractéristiques du
langage humain par rapport au langage
animal l'expression d'un esprit qui
superpose à la réalité concrète et
naturelle une réalité abstraite et
culturels
c'est volontairement que j'emploie le
mot esprits parce que le mot langage
véhicule quelque chose de plus que la
simple parole
le mot langage
l'étymologie du mot langage
ses logos
et logos ça veut dire la raison
donc quand les êtres humains échangent
des mots ils n'échangent pas seulement
des informations pratiques
ils échangent également des idées
ils échangent du sens
c'est ça la différence
et c'est ce qui fait que lorsqu'on est
doté d'un langage commun
quand on est capables de s'entendre
grâce au langage
on devient beaucoup plus performant
collectivement performant
c'est le sens de la coopération permis
par le langage humain qui a permis
d'édifier les civilisations
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
la tour de babel c'est cette allégorie
de la coopération des hommes par le
langage
des hommes qui devenait dès lors une
menace pour dieu
dieu a divisé
en créant toutes les langues pour que
les hommes se retrouvent dans
l'incapacité de coopérer
la coopération on fait concurrence à
dieu lui même
parce que la coopération
geslin possible
parce que la coopération fait sortir de
terre des maisons des villes des
industries c'est à dire des choses
qu'aucun individu seul ne serait en
mesure d'envisager
et quel que soit notre jugement
justement sur ce que la civilisation
humaine à édifier
force est d'admettre
que ce cas-là édifié
et pas seulement le fruit de son orgueil
mais aussi le fruit de la coopération
et pour rester dans les récits mythiques
remarquons que le mythe de prométhée
corrobore cette idée
le mythe de prométhée qui nous dit que
pour que les hommes puissent survivre
face aux autres animaux prométhée leur a
transmis le feu sacré des dieux
le feu représentant l'intelligence est
donc l'expression de l'intelligence par
le langage
en donnant le feu de l'intelligence aux
hommes
prométhée leur donner le moyen de
coopérer par le langage
et ainsi
surpasser les dieux
c'est très simple
rendre cette idée le fait que le langage
humain ne se réduit pas au simple signal
sonore
on y pleure ou qui crient
d'un enfant qui extériorise une
sensation
et c'est aux parents d'interpréter ce
signal sonore pour comprendre ce que
l'enfant réclame
dix ans l'enfant va apprendre à
verbaliser
c'est à dire
si lisez le verbe
la parole construite et élaborée
pour exprime m d'abord ses besoins
puis ses désirs
c'est
l'enfant qui pleure parce qu'il a faim
ne pense pas
ce son esprit qui se verra balises
or
la prend
âge c apprentissage de la verbalisation
de l'esprit
id eu le verbe
mais au commencement il eu l'esprit
verbe c'est l'esprit en tant qu il se
manifeste
c'est l'esprit en tant qu'île
s'extériorise de lui-même dans le temps
c'est exactement ça qu'il se produit
quand on exprime une idée
d'élan et nos maux viennent exprimer
l'idée
une séquence temporelle
c'est pour ça que les conversations sont
moins une affaire de mots
qu'une affaire de rythme
en tous les cas retenons que pour
aristote définir l'homme comme un animal
politique
c'est le définir comme un animal doté
d'un langage lui permettant de coopérer
et d'édifier des normes de vie commune
si on voulait aller encore un peu plus
loin dans l'analyse de la phrase
d'aristote
on pourrait préciser que sa citation
complète n'est en fait pas l'homme est
un animal politique
mais l'homme est par nature un animal
politique
c'est très intéressant
non pas que ça calmant le sens de la
phrase initiale
mais parce que ça apporte un élément de
réflexion décisif sur la question du
rapport entre nature et culture
en règle générale il est convenu de dire
que la culture et ceux qui s'opposent à
la nature
mais si on y réfléchit c'est un peu
ambigu
parce que la cud pas de nulle part
la culture est le produit de la nature
inventé le langage
s'il a inventé l'art la morale
c'est parce que c'était dans sa nature
d'inventer le langage l'art et la morale
les facultés humaines qui lui ont permis
de créer la culture sont inscrits dans
sa nature
pour reprendre l'exemple de l'enfant qui
apprend à parler
parce que l'enfant à la capacité
naturelle c'est-à-dire la capacité
physiologiques de produire du sens et de
l'exprimer qu'il peut apprendre à parler
la culture n'est jamais séparés elle
n'est jamais dissocié de la nature
et donc si on suit le raisonnement
d'aristote ça consiste à dire qu'en
créant la société l'homme ne sort pas de
sa nature mais au contraire il accomplit
sa nature
il nature d'une chose
sens
et les sens d'une chose c'est ce que
cette chose est voué à être
c'est ce qu'elle sera dans son stade
ultime
c'est à dire une fois qu'elle aura
accompli son potentiel
c'est la distinction qu'on trouve en
philosophie entre exister en actes et
exister en puissance
exister en actes ça veut dire exister
dans les faits
l'acte c'est ce qui est
alors qu'existaient en puissance ça veut
dire exister de manière potentielle
ça veut dire être en germe
la puissance c'est ce qui n'est pas
encore réalisée mais qui contient en soi
son principe de réalisation
n c'est la fleur en puissance
rennes n'est pas encore la fleur
elle n'a pas encore actualisé sa nature
mais la nature de la graine n'est pas de
rester grain
nature de la graine c'est de devenir
fleurs
bien la même façon
nature de l'homme n'était pas de rester
un animal parmi les animaux
la nature de l'homme
c'était d'actualiser son potentiel
d'homme c'est à dire de devenir un être
social
et là j'aimerais andres quelques
instants pour explorer un peu plus en
profondeur cette notion de nature
parce que chez aristote
thür ce n'est pas seulement les sens
ce n'est pas seulement ce qu'une chose
est voué à devenir
la nature c'est aussi l'univers
en grec
1 en tant que manifestation physique
doté d'une intelligence
pourquoi doté d'une intelligence parce
que pour aristote et pour les anciens en
général
la nature n'est pas seulement un
agglomérat d'atomes
l'agglomérât d'atomes ne donne pas un
univers ordonnée
matière qui n'est pas ordonnée
une matière qui n'est pas organisé ça ne
donne pas l'univers
a dole le chaos
or l'univers n'est pas chaotique
l'uni organisée
rappelons le cosmos en grec
dire harmonie
et le fait que l'univers soit organisé
le fait qu'il soit structuré par des
lois
c'est ce qui le rend intelligible
pour que l'uni soit intelligible il faut
nécessairement qu'il soit organisé
il faut qu'on a vous régularité des
récurrences il faut que les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets parce que
sans nos équations ne fonctionne plus
imaginez si à tout moment l'univers
pouvait désobéir à ses propres lois
s'il pouvait changer les principes de
son organisation
l'univers viendrez littéralement
incompréhensible
donc l'univers est organisée
et pour aristote
l'organisation est la marque d'une
intention
6 am ans elle est la marque d'une
finalité
c'est ce qu'on appelle une vision
finalistes c'est à dire une vision dans
laquelle chaque chose existe en vue d'un
but
en vue d'une finalité
l'idée qu'on retrouve dans la phrase la
nature est bien faite
dire que la nature est bien faite
c'est dire qu'elle ne produit rien en
vain
autrement dit tout ce que la nature
créée à une utilité du point de vue de
sa propre perpétuation
du point de vue de son propre
fonctionnement
et si là là dessus ne produit rien en
vain
ça veut dire que l'impuissance de
l'homme lorsqu'il est seul a aussi une
fonction
action
c'est de pousser les hommes à s'associer
avec leurs semblables pour former une
communauté
pour aristote l'homme est par nature un
animal politique car la nature a créé
les hommes de telle sorte qu'ils soient
interdépendants
et donc pas la nécessité de s'unir aux
autres par l'intermédiaire du langage
donc suit le raisonnement d'aristote
que les hommes vivent en société n'est
pas un accident de l'histoire
1 un hasard de l'histoire
ces cités
c'est une cité au sens où les hommes
ayant été créée limitée ayant été créée
démunis lorsqu'ils sont seuls ils
n'avaient pas d'autre choix que de
coopérer pour survivre
c'est parce que nous sommes impuissants
quand nous sommes seuls et que cette
impuissance nous condamne à la mort
qu'elle devient paradoxalement le moteur
de notre salut
parce qu'elle devient le moteur de notre
union
les hommes sont condamnés à coopérer
je cite
ce que chose et une fois que sa genèse
est complètement achevé c'est cela que
nous disons être la nature de cette
chose il est manifeste à partir de cela
que la cité fait partie des choses
naturelles et que l'homme est par nature
un animal politique et que celui qui est
hors site et et soit un être dégradée
soit un être surhumain
c'est pourquoi il est évident que
l'homme est un animal politique plus que
n'importe quel abeilles et que n'importe
quel animal grégaire
car comme nous le disons la nature ne
fait rien en vain or seuls parmi les
animaux l'homme un langage certes la
voix est le signe du douloureux et de
l'agréable aussi la rencontre ton chez
les animaux leur nature en effet est
parvenue jusqu'au point d'éprouver la
sensation du douloureux et de l'agréable
et de ce lait signifier mutuellement
mais le langage existe en vue de
manifester l'avantageux et le nuisible
et par suite aussi le juste et l'injuste
il n'ya en effet qu'une chose qui soit
propre sommes par rapport aux autres
animaux le fait que seuls hills est la
perception du bien du mal du juste de
l'injuste et des autres notions de ce
genre or avoir de telles notions en
commun c'est ce qui fait une famille et
une cité
ce buzz il relie les êtres humains les
uns aux autres ce n'est pas seulement un
besoin au sens fonctionnelle du terme
ce n'est pas seulement des compétences
de l'autre que nous avons besoin
c'est aussi
c'est dire
mentalement
sa présence
2 isolement c 11
fou
dans l'isolément dans la sep
so l'ue vis-à-vis d'autrui
il est possible de vivre
impossible d'exister
existait
x6 théret ça veut dire sortir de soi
ça veut dire se manifester
existait c'est être pour un autre
parce que c'est par le détour de l'autre
en conscience de mon existence
existait ces êtres l'extérieur de
l'autre
c'est être aux yeux de l'autre
lorsque robin zoé fait naufrage
mr préoccupations
survivre physiquement
survivre physiquement en étant seul
mais une fois
s'adapter à son milieu et à y satisfaire
ses besoins vitaux
sa préoccupation devient
survivre psychiquement
film seul au monde
le personnage joué par tom hanks
s'invente un ami imaginaire en la
personne de son ballon de volley ball
et lui donne même un nom wilson
dérive au large
son manque de se noyer pour pouvoir le
récupérer
il crie son des espoirs
lui demande pardon
parce que ce qu'il perd à ce moment là
ce n'est pas un ballon de volée
c'est l'autre
c'est là de l'autre qui disparaît
ce ballon réalisé pour te ment x
existence pour un autre
son existence
du monde et de la société
quand robin zooey rang
endredi pour la première fois
celui ci
m d'exister
et siro on a donné pour nom à vendredi
un jour de la semaine
ce n'est pas pour rien
c'est parce que
c'est un peu tact avec la syrie
re 1 vendredi
et se vendent
son de rester
connecté au monde
de vivre au même
et que le monde
savoir les
sépare m
r le monde
nous avons besoin l'autre pour survivre
mais nous avons aussi besoin de l'autre
pour exister
car sans l'eau qui suis-je sinon
une conscience qui errent dans le monde
je vous remercie
[Musique]